what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and black panther
wakanda forever is officially out in
theaters today we're going to be going
over a little bit of the ending but
breaking down that post-credit scene so
if you have not seen the movie and you
are trying to avoid spoilers this is
your official spoiler alert now most
likely if you are still here you have
seen the movie or you simply don't care
about spoilers but if you have seen the
movie let us know in the comments down
below what you thought about it you can
rank it between 1 to 10 or a to F or
simply just give us your thoughts about
it now black panther wakanda forever was
obviously a really really big movie for
a lot of reasons the biggest of course
being the fact that we lost Chadwick
Boseman who played Black Panther slash
t'challa it's incredibly sad and of
course he will be missed by everybody
his death came as a huge shock to pretty
much everybody except his immediate
family surrounding him he didn't even
tell the people over at Marvel Studios
that he had cancer so when he passed
away it was a big shock not only to the
world but to Marvel Studios as well even
the director of the first black panther
and black panther wakanda forever didn't
know he shared recently that he finally
finished the Black Panther 2 script
which of course had Chadwick in it at
the time he asked Chadwick Boseman if he
wanted to look at it before he sent it
to the studio in which Chadwick said no
but Ryan coogler has stated in an
interview he thought that Chadwick felt
too tired to read it Ryan coogler went
on to say Chadwick Boseman would die
about two weeks later now shortly after
the passing of Chadwick Boseman Marvel
Studios came out and we listened to
president Kevin feige tell us that they
decided to not recast t'challa slash the
Black Panther in the MCU now whether or
not people agreed with this decision or
not I think most people understood why
Marvel Studios decided to do this
however there was still a big movement
out there calling for the recasting of
t'challa because how much the character
means to a lot of people plus not to
mention there are a ton of stories that
you can do in the MCU but in the comics
are heavily revolved around t'challa
well in this post those credit scene
they kind of found a way to still please
the fans a way to bring t'challa back
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe but
also a way that gives us time to mourn
the death of Chadwick in Black Panther
wakanda forever the movie starts off
with a scene of shuri actually trying to
recreate a synthetic heart-shaped herb
because her brother King t'challa is
dying however sadly Queen ramonda comes
in and tells shuri that her brother is
gone they say he died from an unknown
illness and we have a funeral for King
t'challa and this movie is very much
about not only the characters grieving
but also the actors as well in fact
there are sometimes in the movie where
you can't tell if they are acting or
simply grieving for a friend so in the
post-credits scene we see shuri burning
the Robes of t'challa something that she
was going to do with her mother earlier
on in the movie as a part of the
grieving process and as a way to move on
shuri becomes the New Black Panther in
this film so the mantle of the Black
Panther is still there however with King
t'challa gone the character t'challa was
gone as well until Marvel figured out a
great way to to still have a t'challa in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in the
movie we find out that Nakia is living
in Haiti at one point in time Nakia
tells shuri she's always welcome at her
house and at the very end of the film we
see Sherry go to nakia's house which is
on the beach and shuri goes down to the
beach and performs the ritual we have a
really nice scene here paying tribute to
Chadwick Boseman and t'challa showing us
clips from Black Panther 1 and this
shows us shuri going through the
grieving process and essentially finally
deciding to move on the movie ends here
but the post-credit picks up right after
in the same exact scene we see Nakia
come out and greet shuri on the beach
but she has somebody with her a young
boy and she tells that young boy that
shuri is his aunt she says that his name
is tassant but then he tells shuri that
my mom says you can keep a secret and he
says that tosantis is Haitian name and
his real name is actually t'challa and
this is where it is revealed that Nakia
and t'challa had a son together and this
is their son he even says I am Prince
t'challa son of King t'challa this comes
as a pretty big shock to shuri but of
course it is an extremely happy moment
and not gonna lie it got me pretty good
in the theater but from here Nokia
explains that King t'challa said that he
didn't want to raise his son in the
Kingdom but he actually did prepare
Nakia and his son t'chella for his death
throughout the movie where Nokia comes
back she meets many different characters
along the way that she hasn't seen in a
very long time like koi Queen ramonda
and shuri they each expressed that they
missed her at the funeral however if you
notice shuri and akoyi were a little
hurt that they didn't see her at the
funeral however Queen raimonda simply
says that she missed her this is because
as we find out t'challa and Nakia told
the queen about their son and queen
raimonda actually met their son as well
Nakia reveals to Sherry that t'challa
told them not to visit the funeral
because if they visited the funeral
instead of focusing on grieving and
saying their goodbyes to King t'chella
they would be more surprised and taken
back by the fact that t'challa has a son
and that they kept him from him for all
these years but Queen raimonda knew this
so instead of being kind of hurt by the
fact that Nakia did not attend the
funeral she simply says that she missed
her so I think this is a pretty great
move by Marvel Studios because now we do
essentially have a recasting of t'challa
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
recently with black panther wakanda
forever coming out of course they've
been doing a ton of interviews leading
up to the movie and Kevin feige has
revealed that the reason that they did
not recast t'challa for black panther 2
was because they felt it was too soon so
this basically confirmed that they
didn't think that they weren't going to
ever recast t'challa simply they did not
recast him for the specific black
panther wakanda forever movie because
now in the post-credits scene it's very
clear that they in their own way have
recast t'challa this t'challa will
essentially go on to become the same
character which is really great because
we have everything that Chadwick Boseman
gave us as his t'challa but now with
this new one his son will get to see
many different storylines play out in
the MCU that have played out in the
comics that fans really really want to
see the X-Men are now making their way
to the MCU and a big storyline in the
comics is the marriage between the X-Men
Storm and King t'challa they also do go
on to have a son together in the comics
and now that we again have a t'challa in
the MCU all these storylines are
possible whereas they were not before
it's most likely that we're going to see
somewhat of a time Jump with t'challa
although hopefully not too big of a time
Jump because now it's possible for
t'challa to actually go on to become a
young Avenger Marvel has been setting up
the Young Avengers for quite some time
now in the MCU so this would be a really
really cool opportunity to have a young
t'challa be a part of the Young Avengers
team then eventually do a Time jump
again and have him grow up to become the
king of wakanda and take the
heart-shaped herb and become the Black
Panther I'm sure shuri will always kind
of keep the mantle of the Black Panther
this did happen in the comics and there
is totally room for two black panthers
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe right
now or it could be that when t'challa
finally becomes of age to be king of
wakanda shuri would step down from the
Black black panther mantle and let her
nephew have it there are also other
major stories involving Namor that we
could see in the MCU again as well like
The Avengers vs the X-Men which still
also ties into storm the Phoenix Force
possesses the Phoenix 5 and Namor ends
up flooding wakanda killing a lot of
people kind of what we saw in Black
Panther wakanda forever however t'challa
is on the side of the Avengers and his
wife storm is on the side of the X-Men
and after the flooding of wakanda black
panther tells his wife storm that he
wants a divorce but in the comics the
wedding between t'challa and storm is a
really big deal everybody comes to watch
it and even The Watcher himself shows up
to witness the ceremony so by Marvel
Studios deciding to essentially not
recast t'challa right away but now bring
in another t'challa this is their way of
recasting the character and now all of
these story options are available moving
forward in the MCU it's definitely a
really really happy ending for a really
sad situation Chadwick Boseman and
t'challa were definitely definitely
missed in this film their absence was
very felt but I think he would have felt
pretty great about how the movie came
out and how they're going forward with
t'challa in the MCU but hey let me know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below what did you think about the
movie and what do you think about the
way they're going about recasting the
character t'challa let us know in the
comments and don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof